so the 2008 and Olympics was my last
Olympics and that was Kobe's first
Olympics so we were all there in Beijing
China what was that experience like for
you to share it with him the Olympics
was great he had such an impact all
around the world especially in China
didn't yes I remember in Beijing we had
two opening ceremonies and they don't
allow like our family or anyone to go
along with the athletes so we're all
together we they call United States we
come out we march and then we get on the
field so of course all the other
athletes from all the other countries
v-line to USA and they want to take
pictures take autographs so of course I
turned into Kobe's bodyguard because it
became so overwhelming with all the
people I'm like forming lines and I have
pictures of so funny I got him backed up
to a staircase and I'm like sit down you
got to sit down because it was
uncontrollable all the people and
everybody from China it was just amazing
how many people wanted out of all the
players there there was a lot of other
players on that 2008 Olympic team but
they wanted Co be the most popular on
the be most popular and it was big names
on that team big names I was complaining
it's not fair he needs security you
can't we can't try to keep off the
masses of all the other countries what
was that experience like for you to
share it with him the Olympics was great
the man came out and supported us as
well as Kobe when they knew that I was
getting my fourth throw in big bill
meadow hopefully you know that our team
will win go we wanted them to win gold
he had such an impact all around the
world especially in China didn't has it
is interesting to me how deeply his of
his death has affected so many different
types of people their mourning in China
their mourning in Italy's certainly in
Los Angeles certainly in this country
why do you think people are so deeply
affected in many cases by a man they did
not know we've lost people before yeah
but what is it about him that has made
this so different and so painful for so
many I really think it's the idea that
you root it for him or you didn't
but that was an emotion evoked either
way you know what I keep thinking Lisa
as often as a case it was probably just
another ordinary day for them they've
gone out of the house and gotten in that
chopper so many times and come home all
the time just another ordinary day and
then in seconds your life is forever
changed forever changed it reminded me
of when it happened that day about the
quote about joy and sorrow are
inseparable as when joy is awake sorrow
is asleep and it's just that like sorrow
has been awakened in my life in their
lives and in the world's lives yeah and
I and I thought what was really
interesting is that people who didn't
know Kobe who feel like I don't dare
surprise that they're affected and I'm
like people's souls are affected because
this is a situation where you can't turn
off the emotion you can't suppress it I
do think people were so you know this
was really his second chapter if you
will of life and I do think people were
starting to perceive him differently do
you a hundred percent because once you
retire now he changed and evolved into
where it's okay to open up and let you
know my secrets I'm not trying to beat
you anymore I'm willing to share and in
fact he really took a lot of pride in
mentorships of sharing with you what I'm
doing what my mentality is and it's kind
of one of those things where he was able
to let his guard down and let people see
the other side